[Music]  hey check it out  we're here welcome to key house I could  never get your father we talk about his  life here my kids need a home does it  have to be this one yes  camps is filled with amazing teas listen  rhythms they whisper you heard that  [Applause]  [Music]  holy crow  cuz I knew this possible  [Music]  this isn't a game they don't know what  these keys unlock  meeow meeow you have no idea what's  coming  there is a crazy evil thing who wants  these keys  [Music]  these aren't toys the weapons  these keys  there are legacy  there's something that connects us with  dad  and first it's always with us  you're gonna try on way  it's always there whatever you think you  understand about those keys you don't  [Music]